when did you lose your virginity bring
me back tell us it was later than you
would think okay you know given the girl
that was doing dirty and all this you
know
[Music]
Christina Aguilera makes an unexpected
sex confession on call her daddy I had
you know I had certain dancers that were
like Close Quarter because you have to
like you know you're traveling a lot and
there's you're you have accessibility to
only so many things so you know it is
what it is the singer Dives right in
when Alex Cooper asked what dating was
like at the peak of her stardom I didn't
really have time for that how did you
feel about your sexuality back then I
wanted to always own it it was important
to me I always went for things that I
would feel safe about like you know we'd
have our you know you'd travel and you'd
meet certain people but I was it's so
funny that I gave this Persona because I
probably was like the last person to
lose my virginity yeah despite
Christina's sexualized Persona during
her dirty era
she reveals she didn't lose her
virginity until later in life it was
something that was for me you know what
I mean and that's I guess why my
messages
went the way they did too is because I
owned it first maybe but yeah it's just
it's more of a funny thing looking back
where it's just like people thought
probably like you were popping off
as far as when it happened the Grammy
winners keeping that to herself it means
everything but when it comes to dating
within the industry Christina makes it
clear it was never her thing I've had my
experiences but I also like
oh I mean my life is hectic enough and
like this is a very narcissistic
industry and like my anxieties couldn't
maybe take somebody that did the exact
same thing I did and like ran around and
traveled it's like I know how this goes
I've definitely like not been into the
celebrity thing I feel like guys next
door Christina's fiance Matt rutler
falls into that category he's a
production assistant who met Christina
on the set of her 2009 musical flick
burlesque
yeah and it seems like the two who've
been engaged since 2014 and share a
daughter Summer Rain have a healthy
relationship in the bedroom it's
important to like be with a partner
where you can really just explore and
there's still a lot more things that I
have not explored yet that are on my
to-do list Christina didn't hold back
the dirty details what is your favorite
part about sex
getting off
I mean like but it's not that cut and
dry I mean I I love a lot of positions
sometimes it's nice like early in the
morning like from your side from behind
and it's like there's like holding
involved and like you know spooning and
Bob I'm gonna own my sexuality for
myself sexuality is a beautiful thing
and we need to take care of it as women
[Music]
thank you